the Joe Rogan experience how's it any
weirder than some of these parasites
that uh ever seen those videos of frogs
that have the parasites in their
eyeballs and they're swimming around
their eyeballs no show
creepy man really yeah they're getting
eaten from the inside out these
parasites that are in their eyeballs
this poor frog said never to read it and
these these worms are squirreling all
around like visibly under its eyeballs
yeah
[ __ ] dude my brother-in-law he's a
cinematographer he shoots nature stuff
so he goes like deep into the Amazon he
shot he shot the first live I want to
say Rhino or hippopotamus birth ever
found that poor frog holy [ __ ] dude
nature doesn't give a [ __ ]
nature is just going to war 24/7 finding
new ways to [ __ ] up animals testing
their systems dam breaking through and
establishing dominance inside this poor
[ __ ] creatures eyeball Wow bro please
so my brother-in-law was in he was in
the Amazon he was shooting I think it
was a first live hippo or a rhino birth
and he comes back and he's visit us out
in California he's got this he's got
this bump on his arm and it's got a red
line running up his arm which means
there's some kind of a bad infection
right so they shoot him up full of
antibiotics they say you'll be fine so
he's driving up the up the PCH going up
to Malibu with his family and he's
poking at it he's he's trying to pop it
like a zit and all sudden the thing just
[ __ ] explodes and this being this
creature [ __ ] flies out of him and
lands on the floor of the car and he's
like looking around it's like little
creature and the kids are [ __ ] gone
and he's like he's like it [ __ ]
jumped out of me and like they're
freaking out and they they brought it to
the tropical disease spread they brought
it to he went to the hospital say what
the [ __ ] is this they sent it to the
tropical disease specialist and they
found out it was a bat fly larvae
yeah disgusting yeah you said she was a
babe come on
play that look at that that super zit
there's a there's a crazy Netflix
documentary on rats that as a rat that's
infected with a botfly and it's like you
know 20% of its neck yeah the thing is
this enormous huge [ __ ] oh god they're
extracting it whoa look at that
yeah and it's got a little head how
weird man that little [ __ ] was living
inside that guy's body yeah and so they
come out so look at that man well that
they think can't look around though it
flies out doesn't it just come out of
salva like that maybe it's cuz he was
squeezing it did it flew away but it's
shot it's shot out when does it become a
botfly like it's a larva it so it looks
like it how it buries itself into the
ground and then becomes that without the
kemaman how's it any different than a
monster all right look at that it's just
little it's a monster it's a whole
insect world is those scariest horror
movie that's ever existed the scariest
monster movie ever is the whole insect
world we are so lucky that like spiders
black widows and tarantulas we're so
lucky that they're little yeah so lucky
so the radiation starts dude we would
have no chance yeah you imagine if
praying mantises or the size of horses
just running around snatching people or
other Priuses yeah it's tipping over the
[ __ ] car and pulling the people out
of the back seats we'd all be armed
you'd have all kinds of firearms on you
would have to have a really high caliber
rifle to penetrate the exterior shell of
a praying mantis if it was a scale and
you probably would even hurt it that
much oh they're extracting it look at
this yo and look how they have to do it
kind of slowly they have to slowly ease
it out oh my God look at the size of
that thing that's in this person's calf
that's the thing about like being in the
jungle is forget about the [ __ ]
Tigers and the Panthers how about the
botflies look how big I'm nauseous I
just leave that dirty hippie that's
that's getting this treatment you see
they have those wrist wrist bracelets
he's playing a second line me know look
at the bracelets you almost deserve a
botfly if you wear those bracelets
here's a second oh my god there's more
than one by far
Jesus Christ look at the size of this
[ __ ] thing look at the size this is
the second one in this hole what the
[ __ ] man that's so insane that's so
insane wow that's gross
[Applause]